The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SHAWN COLE: Great.
It's a real pleasure to be
here and thank you for
listening to me.
This is perhaps the capstone
lecture of the course or at
least the last lecture
of the course.
And I'm going to try to pick
up right where Michael left
off talking about intention
to treat and moving on to
treatment of the treated.
But with any luck, they'll be
some time at the end where we
can have more general
discussions or questions if
people are still interested
about particular topics or
have questions.
And I'll stay after class
to talk to people.
And I think you have my
email on the slides.
So feel free to get in touch
with me at any time.
We've got this great project.
We want to evaluate
it or write JPAL.
So what are we going
to do today?
Look at some challenges to
randomized evaluations.
So these problems.
So basically, when people don't
do what you assign them
to do because you can't
control them.
You can control undergraduates
in a lab, but in the real
world it's a lot harder.
Then we're going to talk about
sort of how do you choose
which effects to report
in your study?
So you've got your study, you
did a bunch of household
surveying, what do you
want to report?
How credible are your results?
Then we'll spend some time
talking about external
validity, which is sort of the
question, OK, I have a study
that I think is internally
valid.
We did the randomization
correctly and the results we
think are legitimate.
But how much can that tell
us about the greater
world around us?
And finally, we'll conclude
by talking about cost
effectiveness.
Which, as economists, is
very important to us.
So we may have a program that's
effective, but how do
we compare whether we should
spend our precious aid or
budget dollars on that
particular program as composed
to a host of other programs?
And so I usually teach at HBS
in the case method, which is
very different than a lecture
format because it's basically
the students always talking
and me refereeing.
I'm not going to do that
today, but I'm very
comfortable with interruptions,
or questions,
or requests for clarification,
et cetera.
And I think we all stay more
engaged if there's more
discussion.
And so that's super valuable.
So that's the outline
for today.
And the slides up here are going
to differ a little bit
from the slides that you have
printed out because there was
some last minute optimization
and re-coordination.
So the basic problem, which I
think Michael talked about, is
that individuals are allocated
to treatment groups and they
don't receive treatment, or
individuals are allocated to
the assignment group,
but somehow
managed to get treatment.
So you talked about students
didn't show up at school, so
they didn't get the treatment
on the treatment day.
Or the program said you can't
give this program, you can't
give de-worming medicine to
girls over the age of 13
because of health reasons.
They may be pregnant and we
don't know how the de-worming
medicine affects pregnancy.
So what do you do?
You came up with the solution
of estimating the program
effect, ITT.
Which is to use the original
assignment.
So we have our baseline survey,
our baseline list of
schools or people and we flipped
our coins or run our
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] code
to randomize.
So then it would just evaluate
them no matter what actually
happened and them.
We count them in the treatment
group or we count them in the
control group.
And that gives us our intention
to treat estimate.
And so the interpretation of
that is, what was the average
effect on an individual in the
treated population relative to
an individual in the comparison
population?
And you've already covered
this with Michael?
This is just a review.
So is this the right
number to look for?
Well, if you're thinking about
putting in a de-worming
program, you have to realize
that people aren't going to be
at school when the government
shows up to administer the
de-worming program to
all their students.
And that's that.
So maybe we can just pause for
a second and think about some
programs that if you're
an [? IPARA ?]
you think you're going to be
involved with, or if you're
involved in an NGO, the type
of program you're running.
And maybe a few people can
volunteer what the intent to
treat estimate might look like
in their evaluation and
whether it's something
they care about.
Put this into practice.
I should be comfortable with
long pregnant pauses as well.
Any examples?
Excellent.
AUDIENCE: So one of the projects
that we're working on
is looking at the impact of
financial education in low
income communities
in New York City.
Obviously we're trying to
measure the impact that
financial education has, but
we're working specifically
with a certain NGO to implement
that education.
Whatever estimate we get that's
the intention to treat
will just be measuring the
impact of the program.
SHAWN COLE: And so what are the
compliance problems you
anticipate there?
AUDIENCE: Maybe people not
showing up for classes or not
following through on whatever
they're asked
to do in the education.
SHAWN COLE: Or people in the
control group could get on the
internet and download the
government's financial
literacy program and study
very industriously
themselves and learn.
The intention to treat will tell
you what the program does
and you could imagine that if
only 15% of the people turn up
for your meetings, you're going
to have a pretty small
difference between the treatment
group and the
comparison group.
That'll be an accurate measure
of the program, but that's not
going to tell us much about
how important financial
literacy is in making
financial decisions.
So if maybe your outcome
variable is what interest rate
do people borrow at, or do they
pay their credit cards
back on time, you might
not find much effect.
From that we can't conclude
that financial education
doesn't affect credit card
repayment behavior.
We just have to conclude that
this particular program we
delivered wasn't
very effective.
So that's an example.
Any other examples?
The point is hopefully
pretty clear.
Great.
So I don't know if you went
through these calculations.
Yeah, OK.
It's absolutely simple.
You just take the average in
this one, average in this one,
and it's the difference.
So it's not rocket science.
So it relates to the actual
program and it gives us an
estimate of the program's
impact.
I guess the second method we're
going to talk about,
which you talked about in your
learning groups this morning
too, is treatment
on the treated.
And maybe you could motivate
this by telling the joke about
the econometricians or
statisticians who went hunting.
Have you heard this?
So the first one aims at a deer
and shoots and misses 10
meters to the left.
And the second one aims at
the deer and misses 10
meters to the right.
And the third one says,
yes, we got it.
So the intention to treat is
giving us the average program
effect, but maybe we care more
about what's the effect of
knowing financial literacy?
What's the effect of actually
changing people's
understanding of financial
literacy?
And that's where the treatment
on the treated estimate can
provide some assistance.
So again, we went back to the
worming example which you
talked about.
And so we have 76% of the
people in the treatment
schools got some treatment
in the first round.
And in the next round
it was 72%.
So that's actually nowhere
near 100%.
One-fifth of the students
are not getting
their de-worming medicine.
And some students in the
comparison group received
treatment also.
So for example, I think when you
were testing the children
and you found that they had
worms in the comparison group,
the sort of medical protocol
required you
to give them treatment.
So what would you do if you
wanted to know the effect of
medicine on the children
who took the medicine?
And so you can't just compare
children who took the medicine
with children who didn't
take the medicine.
That leads to all the same
selection problems we had in
the first few days of class
where the people who decided
not to come to school that day
or weren't able to make it to
school that day are different
than the people who did.
And the people in the comparison
group who went out
to the pharmacy and bought the
de-worming medicine are going
to be different than the
people who didn't.
So what we do in this case is
something really quite simple
and it's at the foundation of
the entire field of modern
empirical research.
But we won't go into all the
details, we'll just talk about
this treatment on the treated
estimator, or ToT.
And so what you don't do is just
take the change of the
people who were treated and the
change of the people who
were not treated and
compare them.
That would be just silly because
people who are treated
are different than the people
who are not treated.
So I think conceptually, this
is actually a really simple
thing that we're doing.
So I don't want to get bogged
down or confused in the math.
But in the ideal experiment, in
the treatment group 100% of
the people are treated.
In the comparison group, 0%
of the people are treated.
And then the average difference
is just the average
treatment effect.
But in real life when we do our
experiments, we very often
have leakage across groups.
So the treatment control
difference is not 1, 100% in
the treatment group treated
and 0% in the
control group treated.
But it's smaller.
The formal econometric
phrase for this is
instrumental variables.
We instrument the probability of
treatment with the original
assignment and this will rescale
the difference in
means to give us a better
estimate of what the effect of
the treatment on the people
who were treated is.
So this is a simple example.
And it turns out it gets
more complicated.
We're not going to go into
all the nuances.
But just suppose for simplicity
that children who
get the treatment have a weight
gain of A, irrespective
of whether they're in
the treatment or
in the control school.
And children who get no
treatment have a weight gain
of B. Again, in both schools.
And we want to know A minus B,
the difference between getting
treated and not getting
treated.
This is the math.
And maybe it looks complicated,
but it's really not.
I think if we work through the
Excel worksheet explaining
what we're doing and then go
back to the math, it'll become
pretty clear.
Imagine we run this experiment
with pupils in School 1 and
pupils in School 2.
We intended to treat everybody
in School 1.
We intended for everybody
in School 2 to be
in the control group.
Unfortunately, we were only able
to treat 6 out of the 10
people in this group and 2 out
of the 10 people in this group
managed to get treatment
somehow.
The formula sort of guides us
through what we need to do and
then we can talk about the
intuition between what it is.
Is there a heroic soul who's
willing to try and just talk
through the math
and figure out?
A non-heroic soul?
Cold call.
So, Will, let's start out
with the easy stuff.
So the formula we want is the
average in the treatment group
minus the average in the control
group divided by the
probability of treatment in the
treatment group minus the
probability of treatment
in the control group.
OK, so how do we calculate
all of these things?
AUDIENCE: So first you want to
look at the change in the
treatment group.
So you average out the observed
change in weight for
the treatment group.
SHAWN COLE: Great.
OK, so that's three.
AUDIENCE: You do the same
calculation for the control
group looking at the average
change in weight.
You take the difference between
those two numbers and
that's the numerator of
the proper fraction.
SHAWN COLE: OK, so
that's yt minus--
OK.
AUDIENCE: And then to do the
second half of the calculation
you've got the denominator.
Compare the rate of compliance
in the treatment group to the
rate of compliance in
the control group.
So the percentage in the
treatment group that actually
complied would be 0.6.
SHAWN COLE: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Awesome.
OK.
AUDIENCE: And for the control
group, it would be
the 2 out of 10.
So the rate that received
the treatment.
So 0.6 minus 0.2.
SHAWN COLE: 0.6 minus 0.2.
OK.
And now?
AUDIENCE: Just divide
the top and bottom.
SHAWN COLE: OK, so
that's the math.
See if we got it right.
Yes, we got it right.
Excellent.
So what's the intuition behind
what we're doing here?
AUDIENCE: You're sort of doing
a weighted average.
SHAWN COLE: OK, we're certainly
taking the two
averages and we're taking
the difference of them.
And what do you mean
by weighting?
AUDIENCE: You're weighting
them by the degree of
compliance.
SHAWN COLE: So if the difference
in compliance--
keeping the top term the
same, so suppose
that this is still--
AUDIENCE: If compliance were
really horrible you'd end up
with no effect.
It could swap the difference
between the
control and the treatment.
SHAWN COLE: OK, so let's take
the mental exercise, keeping
this yt minus yc the
same at 2.1.
If the compliance in the
treatment group goes down from
0.6 to 0.3, what's going to
happen to the ToT effect?
Is it going to go up or down?
AUDIENCE: Up.
SHAWN COLE: Why?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
The people that you were
targeting are not receiving
the treatment.
So in a sense, the effect that
you are trying to describe is
not what we would expect would
happen because some of these
people did not comply with what
you were expecting from
the beginning.
AUDIENCE: It could go either
up or down depending on the
second parameter.
SHAWN COLE: OK, so what I want
to do is I want to say there
are four parameters here.
There's the average in
the treatment group.
the control group.
There's the probability of
treatment in the treatment
group and the probability
of treatment
in the control group.
If this goes down, what's the
ToT estimate going to do?
It's going to go?
AUDIENCE: Increase.
SHAWN COLE: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because you previously
underestimated the
effect because not that many
people received the treatment.
SHAWN COLE: So mathematically,
if we're making the
denominator smaller, the size of
the fraction has to go up.
That's just a law
of mathematics.
But the intuition, what I'm
looking for is the intuition.
So what's going on?
So suppose I first tell you
that this difference is 3.
Can you guys not see
these numbers here?
AUDIENCE: No.
SHAWN COLE: That's excellent.
OK, so let me use a blackboard,
I think this'll be
a little bit helpful.
AUDIENCE: So were you asking
just basically that because
not everybody is being
treated it's
diluting the overall result?
SHAWN COLE: Explain this.
Give us the sort of intuition.
I said that this treatment group
has an average of 3 and
the control group has an
average of 0.1 I think.
No 0.9.
And first I told you that the
probability of treatment
conditional on being in the
treatment group is 0.6.
But now I tell you actually
it's much lower.
It's only 0.3.
So we know from the math
that it's going to
be higher, but why?
What's the intuition?
Why does it have to be higher?
AUDIENCE: Because the gap in
outcomes is actually caused by
fewer people.
Meaning that for those two
people it must have been a
really big gap to balance out
the average to still be a lot
higher when everyone else
in the treated group
actually got zeros.
SHAWN COLE: Yeah, absolutely.
So we've got some difference
in observed outcomes.
And that has to be caused by the
fact that there were more
people in the treatment group
treated than in the control
group who were treated.
So if there were a whole lot
of people in the treatment
group treated, then this rate
difference could be just that
the average score is two higher
for each person in the
treatment group, if
everybody in the
treatment group were treated.
But if only three people in
the treatment group were
treated, to raise the average
from 0.9 to 3, you have to
have a really big effect
on those three people.
So that's all the treatment on
the treated estimator is
doing, is it's rescaling this
observed effect to account for
the fact that the difference
is not 1 here.
If we had perfect compliance,
if this were 1 and this were
0, then the denominator of the
fraction would just be 1.
This would look just like the
intention to treat and the
treatment on the treated
estimators would be the same.
But if we have imperfect
compliance, then we can scale
up the effect to account for
the fact that all of the
change has to be due to the fact
that a smaller number of
people were getting
the treatment.
AUDIENCE: Now you can only do
this because you believe there
is no systematic difference for
why people were treated or
not in between these
two groups?
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So there's some technical
assumptions on how you
interpret these effects.
But if we agree that the effect
is basically a constant
effect, so our literacy program
has the same effect on
everybody, then this
is perfectly fine.
And we can do this because
we randomly assigned the
treatment in the control group
so ex ante the two
groups are the same.
Will?
AUDIENCE: So why do you not have
to worry that the people
in the treatment group who
actually comply are the more
motivated batch of the
treatment group?
SHAWN COLE: Right.
That is a concern and it's
covered in the papers, which
I'll get to at the end.
Basically, the sort of
aggressive intuition is that
this tends to measure the
effect on people who are
affected by the program.
But in general, this is a
pretty good way of just
scaling up your program effects
to account for the
possibility of noncompliance.
So moving back to--
sure.
AUDIENCE: Did you answer
his question?
SHAWN COLE: Why do we have
to worry about it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It seemed like it's
a serious problem.
AUDIENCE: It started random, but
then people who actually
got treated, if they were
treated because they were
systematically different
then it's no longer--
your control group is no longer
a good representation
of the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
SHAWN COLE: Right.
There are technical assumptions
about monotonicity
and independence that I sort of
would rather not go into.
But if you'll at least just
grant that there's a constant
treatment effect, then I think
we're fine and by scaling up
the impact to account for the
non-compliers, we'll be OK.
AUDIENCE: Is the idea-- sorry
not to belabor the point.
But is the idea that this method
will get the correct
magnitude of the treatment on
those who are treated in this
study, but you can't necessarily
extrapolate that
to say, that would have
been the same
treatment on the treated.
Would you be able to force these
other people who might
be different in some
way to get treated.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
This will tell you the correct
magnitude of the people who
because they were treated,
get the treatment.
So that's again, a relevant
parameter when you're running
a program that causes people
to take the treatment, you
have the effect.
If on the other hand you're the
government and you have
some ability to compel
compliance, then you might not
get effect.
So you may worry about this.
Some people have done studies to
try and sort of see how big
a problem this is.
And one example I can cite is
some studies on educational
literature.
So in the US people have looked
at mandatory school
attendance laws that say in some
states you can drop out
of school at the age of 16 and
in some states you can drop
out of school at
the age of 15.
And so changes in these
laws induce some
people to stay in longer.
But probably nobody here would
have been affected by one of
these mandatory schooling laws
because we were all planning
to go on to college anyway.
And so people have compared
estimates in the US with those
in the UK where the mandatory
schooling law were very
binding and they found that
the point estimates were
pretty similar.
So that's an example of where
it can be reasonable.
But this is something that you
have to treat with a little
bit of caution.
So there are other challenges
with this.
To get the ToT, we need to
know the probability of
treatment conditional being
on the treatment and the
probability of being treated
condition on being in the
control group.
So why might these
be hard to get?
AUDIENCE: I actually
had a question.
I don't know if it's
directly related.
Does this work if the
probability that you're
treated in both the treatment
and control turn out to be
equal or is there probability
that--
SHAWN COLE: Great question.
So you're anticipating a slide
three slides from now.
So let's go there and
then we'll come
back to my other problem.
But this is the equation.
So what happens if the
probability of treatment and
the treatment in the control
group is the same?
AUDIENCE: Mathematically
you have problems.
SHAWN COLE: Mathematically
you're dividing something by 0
and you're going to get infinity
or negative infinity.
So yeah, that's not
successful.
I mean, another way of
putting that is that
your experiment failed.
You randomly assigned treatment
and you assumed that
your program, a financial
literacy education program,
de-worming medicine, is going
to deliver a product.
But if, in fact, it doesn't
change the probability of
treatment at all, then
your program failed.
It's sort of like if I
were to sit here and
working with an [? MFI, ?]
send them an email and say,
I'm assigning these 50
villages to treatment and these
50 villages to control.
And then the email gets lost and
they don't do any sort of
treatment or control.
And then they send me the
data back a year later
and I do the analysis.
Well, I'm going to find that
there's no difference in
probability of treatment between
the two groups and I
won't have anything interesting
to say.
So that's definitely
one problem.
The experiment doesn't work
unless the treatment induces a
change in probability of
treatment between the
treatment in the comparison
groups.
So that's one problem.
There's a second problem with
this estimation since we're on
this slide, which is perhaps,
slightly more technical.
But if the difference between
the treatment and the
comparison group is small.
So say it's 10% of the treatment
group are treated
and none of the comparison
group is treated.
Then we're estimating the mean
of all of the treated people
minus the mean of all the
control people and dividing by
0.1, which is the same thing
as multiplying by 10.
So if there's a little bit of
noise in these measures, then
instead of--
suppose the true mean
is 3, but you
happened to measure 3.1.
Then that noise is going
to be blown up by a
factor of 10 as well.
So the estimate is going to be
much less precise when the
difference in treatment between
the treatment and the
comparison group is low.
And as you said, if it gets
to 0, you're in a pickle.
AUDIENCE: That's a pretty
extreme problem.
It means I had a treatment
group and
only 10% of the people.
SHAWN COLE: Sure.
That's true, but it's not
implausible that you'd want to
run that type of experiment.
So if you think of--
I don't know the exact numbers
on the flu encouragement
design papers.
To try and understand how
effective a flu shot is, you
can send out letters to a bunch
of people and some of
the people-- the control group,
you just send a letter
saying, just for your
information, the influenza
season is coming.
Please wash your hands a lot.
The treatment group you send a
letter saying that information
plus we're offering free flu
shots down at the clinic, why
don't you come down?
And you may only get
a 10% response
rate from that letter.
But in that case, the treatment
is very cheap.
It's just $0.32, or whatever
a stamp cost these days.
So you could do a study
with 100,000 people.
Then you would estimate both of
these things very precisely
because you'd have 50,000 people
in the treatment group,
50,000 people in the
control group.
And you'd have these numbers and
so you could come up with
an estimate.
It's not like we should give up
on an experiment that has a
low probability of treatment,
it's just if we think we're
going to be there we want
to do our power
calculations carefully.
And I think you would have
seen when you did your--
did your power calculations
include noncompliance?
OK, so if you start adjusting
the power calculations for
noncompliance, you see that you
need larger sample sizes.
And so that's an important
lesson as well.
Sticking with that
flu example.
Why might this be hard?
When we sent out these letters
to all these people either
encouraging them to wash their
hands or encouraging them to
get flu shots.
AUDIENCE: We have
to observe both.
Whether there's treatment in
your control in particular,
that could be really
hard to do.
SHAWN COLE: So maybe if you're
directing them to your flu
clinic, you're going sort of
observe everybody you send a
letter who comes in
for a flu shot.
And maybe they're employees of
Blue Cross Blue Shield or
something and you hope you'll
get a good estimate.
But what about this, you've got
50,000 people you've sent
letters to in the
control group.
What can you do?
Do you have to phone up all
50,000 people and try and--
AUDIENCE: And say, oh, by
the way, did you happen
to get a flu shot.
SHAWN COLE: Exactly.
So do we need to make 50,000
telephone calls
to solve this problem?
AUDIENCE: Randomly sample.
SHAWN COLE: Randomly sample?
So pick 500, even 1,000,
or who knows?
Maybe even 200 people, 300
people will give you a pretty
good estimate of what this is.
You just need to make sure that
it is a randomly selected
sample and you're not just
asking all of the people in
this particular clinic.
We're getting a little
bit out of order.
I've gone through the math, but
PowerPoint wouldn't let
you see it.
But at least suffice it to say
Will talked us through it.
It's not a lot of fancy
econometrics we're doing here.
This is called the Wald estimate
if you've taken
econometrics.
But it's a very simple
method for coming up.
So there's some problems or
there's some areas where this
could be a problem.
And Will hinted at one.
We can mention a
couple others.
So how might this treatment on
the treatment design fail,
let's say, in the
letters example,
the influenza example?
So we're sending out
a bunch of letters.
So suppose the treatment group
is you send out a bunch of
letters saying, it's flu season,
come get a flu shot.
And the control group is you
don't send out any letters.
And so what happens?
Suppose you get 50%
compliance.
So treated and the
control group,
compliance means flu shot.
You get 50%.
Let's make it easy, in the
control group you get 0%.
You do a sample and just
nobody gets a flu shot.
Maybe this is in a developing
country where people don't
tend to think about flu shots.
And suppose you get the flu
rate to be 10% here.
We could say this
is in Mexico.
And 15% here.
Do I have my math right?
Yeah.
So what would the treatment on
the treated estimate here be?
AUDIENCE: 20%?
SHAWN COLE: So what's
the formula?
AUDIENCE: 10 minus 15.
Divided by 0.5.
SHAWN COLE: Minus 0.
So it's minus 10.
So giving the flu shot to a
population will reduce the
incidence of flu by 10
percentage points.
So what's an example of how this
experiment could fail, or
how this number could
not be correct?
AUDIENCE: By reminding people to
get a flu shot, you remind
them that the flu is out there
and they might do other things
besides get a flu shot.
SHAWN COLE: Absolutely.
So now they wash their hands, or
they don't go out in public
places, or they wear masks.
And so you think that you're
reducing the flu a lot by
these flu shots.
But maybe in fact, washing
your hands is a lot more
important than--
in fact, I think it probably
is-- washing your hands off
and is a lot more important
than getting a flu shot.
And that's what's giving
you the effect.
So if you're scaling up this
impact in the treatment on the
treated to give yourself credit
for the fact that 50%
of the people didn't
get a flu shot.
If instead they're actually
washing their hands a lot,
then this won't be the
correct estimate of
treatment on the treated.
Is that reasonably clear?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Will it be a good estimate of
the impact of that specific
intervention on the treated?
So instead of measuring the
impact of the flu shot, you're
measuring the impact of
reminding people about flu
shots and giving them
access to free ones?
SHAWN COLE: So would you want
to scale that up or not?
Which estimate would you
want to take there?
AUDIENCE: Depends on what
you're interested in.
SHAWN COLE: So suppose we're
interested in, what's the
impact of sending a letter
to somebody and
offering them a flu shot?
Is the correct estimate 5
percentage points or 10
percentage points?
AUDIENCE: 5.
SHAWN COLE: Why?
AUDIENCE: Then your intent
to treat is maybe more
interesting because you want
to take into account that
people change their behavior and
their compliance rates are
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So then we're really interested
in the package of
effects that sending a letter
causes, which includes
sometimes getting a
shot, more likely.
But also washing your hands
or being more careful.
So the intent to treat--
and as we say, so if you have
this situation, you should
only use intent to treat.
And intent to treat is very
interesting and it tells us
the effect of sending out
a letter, but it doesn't
necessarily tell us the effect
of the flu shot.
Anybody have any examples from
their own programs or
projected projects where they're
concerned about this?
Maybe you guys can be at least
sure to work this in on your
presentations tomorrow.
What about when you have
spillovers or externalities?
So I think Michael talked
about spillovers and
externalities this morning.
But he might not have
integrated that with
intention to treat.
Is that a correct
characterization of his lecture?
Excellent.
How could we go wrong-- let's
stick to something I know
well-- with the Balsakhi
Program.
In the Balsakhi Program,
we have
treatment and control schools.
And sort of the compliance is
20% in the treatment schools
and 0% in the control schools.
And the change in test
scores is, let's
say, 1 standard deviation.
No, that's going to
be way to high.
0.2 standard deviations
here and 0
standard deviations here.
So quickly, as a review, how do
we get the ITT estimator?
This is what we call
a chip shot at HBS.
But since we're not awarding
points for participation there
aren't a lot of golfers
out there.
AUDIENCE: Intention to treat?
It's just 0.2.
SHAWN COLE: OK and how
did you get that?
You just saw it?
AUDIENCE: You just
subtract it.
You don't have to do anything.
SHAWN COLE: So it's 0.2.
AUDIENCE: Minus 0.
SHAWN COLE: Minus 0.
Over?
AUDIENCE: Wait, are
you saying--
SHAWN COLE: Oh, sorry.
Intent to treat.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, you're right.
Sorry, my bad.
So the intent to treat is 0.2.
And what's the treatment
on the treated?
AUDIENCE: 0.2 minus 0.
SHAWN COLE: Great.
AUDIENCE: Over 0.2 minus 0.
SHAWN COLE: This is confusing.
This is the standard deviations
in test score and
this is the percentage
compliance.
And so what's that
going to give us?
AUDIENCE: 1.
SHAWN COLE: 1.
So wow, that's a spectacularly
effective program.
I was very proud to be
associated with it.
It raised test scores by
1 standard deviation.
Which if you know the education
literature, is a
pretty big impact.
What might we be concerned
about in this case?
So what did the Balsakhi
Program do?
Refresh ourselves.
It takes 20% of the students,
pulls them out of the
classroom during the
regular class, and
sends them to a tutor.
And these are the kids who are
often in the back of the
class, the teacher's not paying
attention to them
because they're only teaching
to the top of the class.
Maybe they're making
trouble, throwing
things around, et cetera.
What could go wrong?
AUDIENCE: You're attributing the
fact to just taking this
class to just those students
in particular.
Whereas you're taking them out
of the class, so you're making
the class that you left
behind smaller.
So there's effects--
SHAWN COLE: Right, so how does
making the class that you left
behind smaller matter?
AUDIENCE: Usually it's easier
to learn in a smaller group.
SHAWN COLE: That's why we teach
a JPAL maximum class
size of 15 or 20.
We hope that small classes
are more effective.
And there's also a tracking
argument that maybe now the
teacher can focus really on the
homogeneous group rather
than having to teach to multiple
levels, et cetera.
So there are all these other
reasons to think that it may
be the case that they're going
to be some spillovers.
So how would you explain in
words to a policymaker why
you're not sure that 1 is
the right effective
treatment on treated?
This is particular for the IPA
folks who will have to be
doing this to earn
their paychecks.
But anybody is welcome.
AUDIENCE: There were sidebar
benefits to the control group.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
Well, not the control group.
AUDIENCE: I mean to the--
SHAWN COLE: Untreated students
in the treatment group.
So we were attributing all of
this test gain to sending
these kids out to class.
But in fact, there could've
been some test gain in the
other groups.
In the extreme, I suppose you
could imagine that there's no
performance gain for the
children who go out to the
Balsakhis, but getting those
misbehaving children out of
the class causes everybody else
to learn so much more
effectively that it raises
the test score.
So the program still has an
effect, but the way it has an
effect is by getting
the misbehaving
children out of the class.
Now it turns out that that's
not the case that there are
sort of some interesting ways
to try and tease out how big
the spillovers were.
And I encourage you to read
the paper if you're
interested.
And it turns out that there's
not really any evidence of
spillovers, so it really does
seem like the effect happened
through the Balsakhi Program.
But it's definitely something we
want to be aware about when
we're doing our analysis.
OK, so we've already
talked about this.
If you have partial
compliance, your
power may be affected.
So the intention to treat is
often appropriate for program
evaluations.
It's simple to calculate.
It's easy to explain.
If you do this program, you'll
get a mean change in your
outcome of 0.3, 0.4, 0.5.
There are a lot of
advantages to it.
But sometimes you may be
interested as well on the
program itself.
And as we said, it measures the
treatment effect for those
who take the treatment because
they're assigned to it.
If you have people who
will never ever
ever take the treatment.
If you tried to run a randomized
evaluation on
Christian scientists who refuse
medical treatment and
you assign them free medical
care, you're not going to find
any effect.
But we can find the effect of
the treatment on people who
take the treatment when
they're offered it.
And so when you're doing the
design of your experiment,
it's important to think through
these issues and think
at the end of the day, at the
end of the study, in two years
time when we've collected all
the data and analyzed it, what
sort of results are we
going to report?
How are we going
to report them?
And how are we going to explain
them to other folks?
So that is intention to treat
and treatment on the treated.
And let's move briefly to the
choice of outcomes and
covariates.
We always look forward to your
feedback from the course.
But in my view, the course might
benefit from a little
bit more focus on some of the
practical aspects of doing an
evaluation.
So for example, survey design
and determining what outcomes.
Although maybe many of you are
already familiar with that.
So often when you do these
randomized evaluations, you do
like a household survey or you
have administrative data on
the individual and you have 100
or you have 150 variables
about them.
So you go into the field with
a 20 page survey and you sit
and you ask, how many
cows do you have?
How many goats do you have?
How much land do you have?
What was your monthly income?
Are your children going
to school, et cetera.
And so if you imagine an outcome
like microfinance,
which we hope causes people to
be more productive and engaged
and boosts household income,
arguably boosts women's
empowerment, et cetera.
There are sort of a lot of
things that could plausibly
happen because you offer
people microfinance.
But from a statistical side,
this offers some challenges.
So what's the problem when
you're interested in how
microfinance affects 40
different outcomes.
So education, consumption,
feelings of empowerment,
number of hours worked.
You know, you can come up with a
lot of plausible things that
you think microfinance
would affect.
AUDIENCE: At a 0.5 level too,
those will come out
significant having
40 even though--
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So for people who haven't done
hypothesis testing, hypothesis
testing, which is what we use
to analyze data says, how
likely is it that the difference
between the
treatment and the control
group is because of the
program or simply because
of random chance?
And so you can look at the
distribution of outcomes in
the treatment group and the
control group and observe
their means and their variances
and the number of
observations, and you can come
up with a rule that says it's
very, very unlikely.
Only 1 in 100 times would this
thing have happened because of
random chance.
The standard that tends to be
used in economics and the
medical literature is this
5% p value, which
is 1 out of 20 times.
But if you're looking at 40
outcomes, then on average, 2
of them are going to be
statistically significant just
out of random chance.
So if I were to just randomly
divide this group, this class
into two groups, and started
looking at things like US born
or foreign born, or Yankees fan
or Red Sox fan, or what
have you, it wouldn't be too
hard to eventually find
something that were
statistically significantly
different between
the two groups.
This is a challenge.
There are a few ways to deal
effectively with this challenge.
So this isn't a particularly
difficult challenge.
So what the medical literature
does in which, I think, we're
sort of slowly moving towards
in social sciences, is you
have to stay in advance where
you expect to find effects.
So if you're going to the FDA
to test the efficacy of a
drug, when you apply for the
phase III evaluation you have
to say, I think this is
going to cure Shawn's
male pattern baldness.
And I think that this is going
to result in a more charming
personality.
And then you find Shawn and all
of his brothers and you
run the experiment.
And then if the outcome turns
out that the treatment group
is now never get sick, simply
immune from all diseases.
In the past year, nobody in the
treatment group got sick,
you can't then go out and market
that drug as something
that cures diseases because
that wasn't your stated
hypothesis test ahead of time.
So oftentimes, we have a
lot of guidance on what
hypotheses to test.
So if we're doing a financial
literacy program, we expect
that to effect financial
outcomes and not employment
and not divorce rates.
Although you could
tell a story that
eventually gets you there.
But when you're reporting your
results to the world then,
what you want to do is report
the results on all the
measured outcomes,
even the ones for
which you find no effect.
So then, anybody who takes the
study can look and say, OK,
they're saying that their
program has a great effect on
income and children's schooling
and health.
But they tested 200 things, so
I'm a little bit skeptical.
Or but they only tested 6 things
and half of them were
large statistically significant
impact, so I
really believe that study.
Maybe it's a little unfortunate
the last class of
the course is about sort of
challenges with randomized
evaluations because I should
just take a sidebar to
emphasize that these problems
we're talking about are not
unique to randomized
evaluations.
Any evaluation you
run these risks.
So if it's just sort of the
standard, what we like to
think of as a pretty bad
evaluation where you just find
some treatment people and find
some associated comparison
people and do a survey, you're
going to run into this exact
same problem.
So don't take many of these as
a criticism as randomized
evaluation, but just take
them as good science.
What to do for good science.
And there are other things you
can do which is to adjust your
standard errors.
So we have a very simple way of
calculating standard errors.
But if you're testing multiple
hypotheses, then you can
actually statistically take that
into account and come up
with sort of corrected
or bounds on
your standard errors.
And those are described in the
literature that I'm going to
refer to you at the end
of the talk as well.
AUDIENCE: What about taking half
your data and mining it?
SHAWN COLE: And throwing
the rest away?
AUDIENCE: No, I mine
half of my data.
I just figure out what really
matters and that's how I
generate my hypothesis.
SHAWN COLE: That sounds
reasonable to me.
AUDIENCE: I better have had
a big enough sample.
SHAWN COLE: Yeah, you better
have had a big enough sample.
I think sort of that
intuition is--
data mining is problematic, but
it is useful when you run
a study to report all of your
results because if there are
some surprising things there, we
don't know whether they're
there because of chance
or because the
program had that effect.
But that gives us sort of a
view on what to do when we
test again.
So if we're going to try this
microfinance program out in
some other country or some other
area of the country, we
said it had this surprising
effect on girl's empowerment.
So now let's make that one of
our key outcomes and let's
test it again.
So I think that sounds
pretty reasonable.
There's a pretty advanced,
developed statistical
literature on hypothesis testing
and how you develop
hypotheses.
But that sounds not unreasonable
to me.
Other thoughts?
So another possibility is
heterogeneous treatment
effects, which is what
we often look for.
So you might think that the
financial literacy program is
more effective with women than
men because women started out
with lower levels of initial
financial literacy, or you
might think that the de-worming
medication is more
effective for children who live
near the river because
then they play outside more
often, or something like that.
And so it's very tempting to
run your regressions for
different subgroups.
But again, there's this risk
that you're data mining.
Suppose I wanted to show that
I randomly assigned you this
group into a treatment
and control group.
And I wanted to show that
Yankees and Red Sox
preferences were significantly
different in the two groups.
I could probably cut the data
in different ways and
eventually find some subset of
you for whom the treatment and
the control variables were
actually different.
And so you want to be aware
of that possibility.
And again, like the FDA drug
trial way to avoid this is
just to announce in advance
which subgroups you expect
this product to be more or less
effective for and make
sure you have a sufficient
sample size to test
statistical significance
within those subgroups.
Again, as a service to all the
consumers of your studies,
report the results on
all the subgroups.
Even the subgroups for whom the
program's not effective.
So there's another
problem that--
did we talk about clustering in
groups, data in the power
calculations?
OK, so that is sort of the bane
of statistical analysis.
Or as we liked to say when I was
a graduate student, sort
of people used to not really
appreciate the importance of
these grouped errors.
It was much easier to write a
paper back then because you
found lots of statistically
significant results.
And once you start using
this cluster
adjustment, it's a lot harder.
Now only 5% of results are
statistically significant.
So we whined that if only we
had graduated five years
earlier, it would have
been much easier to
get our thesis done.
But we here don't care about
getting the thesis done.
We here care about finding out
the truth and measuring the
potential for cluster in
standard errors, or clustering
common shocks from the
group is very strong.
You can often get estimates of
the correlation within groups
using survey data that
you already have.
That will inform your
power calculations.
But when you're doing your
analysis, you need to adjust
your statistical results
for this clustering.
And in particular, you run into
problems when your groups
are very small.
So if you're thinking, I want
to do an evaluation where I
had 15 treatment villages
and 15 control villages.
Well, it's very likely that
outcomes are going to be
correlated within
that village.
And then, all of a sudden, you
only have 30 clusters.
And even the statistical
technique isn't great for
sample sizes that
are that small.
You have to use other
statistical techniques, which
are sort of valid, but
less powerful.
So we won't go into the
randomization inference.
Again, it's mentioned in this
paper I was talking about.
You should be aware of this and
I think the most important
time to think about this is
when you're designing your
evaluation, to make sure you
get enough clusters.
And if you can, it's almost
always preferable to randomize
by individual than group.
Because randomizing by group
requires typically, much
larger sample sizes.
AUDIENCE: Can you just say one
more thing or give us a
reference on what you meant by
other statistical techniques
that are valid, but
not as powerful?
SHAWN COLE: Sure.
Let me just skip to this.
This should be on your
slide package.
The ultimate slide is additional
resources.
And so there's a paper called
"Using Randomization in
Development Economics Research:
A Toolkit, by
Esther, Rachel, and Michael.
And this goes through everything
we've talked about
this week in pretty careful
detail, works out the math,
and gives you references
to what you need.
So it's in there.
Josh Angrist, who's on the
faculty here, has a very good
book called "Mostly Harmless
Econometrics." But it's
designed for academics.
It's not really a textbook.
But it goes through these things
in very, very, very
good detail and it's
fun to read.
But specifically, the
technique is called
randomization inference.
It was developed by Fisher.
And what you do is
you basically--
so you have your treatment and
your control group and your
mean between the treatment and
the mean in the control and
you test the statistical
significance.
And then what you do is you
just randomly reassign
everybody to either treatment or
control, regardless of what
they actually did, and see if
there's a difference between
the treatment and
control group.
And if you do that a hundred
times, you can sort of get a
sense for how often you find
statistically significant
differences or not.
It's related to bootstrapping.
That's a reasonable method, but
the problem with that is
the statistical power's
not very good.
So you need a larger sample.
And then once you have a larger
sample, then you don't
need to worry about it because
you can cluster.
So another question that's
maybe a little bit more
technical is when you're doing
your analysis, your regression
analysis, is what covariates
do you want to control for?
So we're looking at the effect
of financial literacy
education on credit
card repayment.
When we do our statistical
analysis, do we want to
control for the age of the
person, for their gender, for
their initial measured
level of financial
literacy, et cetera.
Now the beauty of randomization
is that it
doesn't matter.
Even if you don't have data on
any of these covariates, as
long as the program was
initially randomly assigned
and the sample size is large
enough, then you'll be OK.
But what the controls can do is
that they can help you get
a more precise estimate.
So if a lot of people's credit
card repayment behavior is
explained by whether they ate a
cookie as a child or not and
you happen to have that
particular data for people who
have been reading The New
Yorker, then you can soak up
some of the variation
and come up with a
more precise estimate.
Or you can control for
age, or control for
income, or other things.
So it's often desirable to
have additional controls.
But what you don't want to do is
control for a variable that
might have been affected by
the treatment itself.
So if you're looking at the
effect of microfinance on
women's empowerment, so that's
the goal of your study.
And then you would say, well,
women who have higher levels
of income report higher levels
of feeling empowered.
So that's an important
determinant of feeling empowered.
We should include that
in our control
when we do our analysis.
But if it turns out that
microfinance increased income
and increased control, then we
might conclude that there's no
effect because we're attributing
the effect to the
differences in income.
Is that clear?
A lot of these are fairly
nuanced issues and it's often
worth consulting an academic
or often a PhD student are
eager to work on projects
like this as well.
Just as a rule, it's important
to report the raw differences
and the regression
adjusted results.
I think we advance a very strong
view that randomized
evaluation is a very credible
method of evaluation.
But even still, there are always
ways to tweak or twist
things a little bit to try and
get the results you want.
So you could have a survey with
a hundred people or a
hundred outcomes and only
report seven of them.
That might make your program
look better than it is.
So these rules we're proposing
are ways to give people an
honest and a thorough
view of the
effectiveness of your program.
So another rule is that when
you're reporting your
regression results, you should
include the results with the
covariates, as well as the
results without the
covariates.
So now let's talk about threats
to external validity.
So we spent a lot of time so
far talking about internal
validity, which is
sort of was the
treatment randomly assigned?
Did enough people in the
treatment group comply that
you have a difference
between the
treatment and control group?
But it's not sufficient to know
that we've learned a lot
from a randomized evaluation.
So there's some threats that
just doing the evaluation
itself may have some impact
above and beyond the program.
And so these are called
Hawthorne and Henry effects.
And maybe we'll go back to the
audience for some examples of
a Hawthorne effect.
So a Hawthorne effect is when
the treatment group behavior
changes because of
the experiment.
What's an example of that?
Anybody familiar with the
original Hawthorne study?
AUDIENCE: Was is the lights
being dimmed or different
levels of lights and workers
felt like they were getting
attention paid to them
no matter what the
light level was at?
It's just that there was
something going on and so
their productivity was higher.
SHAWN COLE: I actually don't
remember the study.
Can I just try and
rephrase that?
You can tell me whether
I'm right.
So the experiment was to try and
figure out how the level
of lighting in a factory
affects productivity?
I suppose.
And so they said we're going to
raise the level of lighting
in this sort of select, maybe
even randomly selected.
We randomly select 50 out of 100
of our work groups and we
roll in an extra light.
And they're like, oh
great, management
really cares about us.
They're including us
in this survey.
They're giving us extra light.
We're going to work
extra hard.
And so you find a higher
output from that group.
Alternatively, if you had said,
maybe people are getting
distracted by having
too much light.
So management picked these 50
groups, went in and unscrewed
some light bulbs.
They're working in sort
of a dim area, they'd
be like, oh, wow.
Management really cares
about our well being.
Now we focus on the natural
light and we're going to work
really hard.
So just the act of sort of being
in the treatment causes
your behavior to change.
And so what's wrong with that?
I mean we're trying to measure
the effect of treatment.
If the effect of treatment
is to increase
productivity, fine.
AUDIENCE: Maybe you can not
make a generalization to a
population that doesn't have
change that behavior because
doesn't get the treatment
already.
AUDIENCE: You run around
changing the light levels at
different factories and you
don't get the effect because
the real treatment was people
running around and testing and
observing and measuring
the change in light.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
And saying, we're really glad
you're part of this study.
It's very important.
AUDIENCE: Which was
really what got
people to work harder.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
You might be able to generalize
that if we decided
to run this study in every
factory in our firm, then we
might get similar results
in different factories.
But probably, within a few
months, people would sort of
just catch on that this is
just kind of wacky, and
what's going on?
It wouldn't really be the
effect of the program.
Any other examples from your
programs of Hawthorne effects?
Or things you might
be worried about?
AUDIENCE: It seems like a lot
of behavior situations,
there's a threat to this.
Especially if you have some in
developing country context
where you have foreigners coming
in or people from the
capitol coming in.
Especially if it's something
that-- again, with a behavior
change where OK, I know I'm
supposed to be washing my
hands with soap.
I normally don't, but I know
that the white people get
really happy when I do it and
they're coming in to evaluate.
So I'm going to go ahead--
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So if you show up from abroad
and put posters encouraging
people to wash their hands,
people may pay more
attention to that.
What does that validate
or not invalidate?
So suppose we did this and we
found that the effect was it
reduces reported incidence
of diarrhea by 15%.
AUDIENCE: If you then don't
still have white people coming
into the village, then the same
effect might not happen.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So I guess it's a little bit
nuanced because we should
distinguish between the program
generalizability,
which is the program could be
white people come into the
village, and Hawthorne effects,
which is because I
know I'm in the treatment group
in the study, I'm going
to act differently.
So what's another example of
really, a Hawthorne effect?
I'm sympathetic to yours as a
Hawthorne effect, but I want
to really sort of nail it.
AUDIENCE: There's one for hand
washing where every week
people go into the villages
and then tell them the
importance of hand washing as
a way to prevent malaria.
And every time they ask them,
did you wash hands?
Do you wash hands?
But that's not sustainable on
a long-term basis because--
and at the same time, you're
distributing free soap.
So how do you separate
everything?
SHAWN COLE: I would say again,
that's the program.
And so we would say if we scaled
that program up to all
of the country, we'd be fine.
If we go in every week and
tell people to wash their
hands and distribute
soap, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: So sometimes on
sexual behavior studies,
you'll find that a treatment
group that is encouraged to
adopt condoms, or something.
And then in the post-measurement
period, they
know what the intervention
is about.
And so if you ask them, what has
your sexual behavior been
in the last week, they're much
more likely to say that
they've been using condoms.
Or change their partnering
habits or these other sorts of
things that have nothing
to do with--
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So the effect of being in the
treatment group and knowing
that you're getting this
treatment might change how you
answer the survey questions,
even if you
didn't behave that way.
Any other?
AUDIENCE: For the Hawthorne
effect?
SHAWN COLE: So it's certainly
a problem with your survey.
AUDIENCE: It might change
other aspects of their
behavior other than condom use
that would be simply because
they know that you're looking.
SHAWN COLE: So I mean I would've
said something like I
know that they really care about
me and so because I'm
part of this MIT Poverty Action
Lab Study, it must be
really important
that I do this.
But if you were to generalize
the program, not as part of a
study, then people would react
to it differently.
The other side of the coin is
the John Henry effect, which
is people in the comparison
group behave differently.
What are examples of that?
AUDIENCE: The village in the
control group is resentful to
the politician who they
perceived as determining who
got treatment status and so
they don't try as hard on
whatever's being measured.
Or they intentionally turn in
a poor performance as a sign
of protest.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
They're like, why am I in the
control group of this study.
I wanted to be in the
treatment group.
I'm not going to use fertilizer
because I know this
study's about fertilizer
or something.
Other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: You could
do the opposite.
I could say, oh, those guys,
they got the treatment.
But I don't need that.
I can do just as well,
so I'm going to--
SHAWN COLE: I'm going to pull
myself by my bootstraps.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE] going
to start studying and
double up and I'll show them.
SHAWN COLE: That's an
interesting problem, is we
don't really know which way
these effects go ex ante.
The Hawthorne or John Henry
effects could be positive or
could be negative and could
be a challenge for the
evaluation.
So how do you sort of try
and address this to
resolve these problems?
AUDIENCE: It'd be hard
to do statistically.
AUDIENCE: This could be
dangerous I suppose.
But if you try to make the
people in the control group,
for instance, feel special
in some other way.
But in a way that you can say
is not related to anything
you're measuring from
the treatment.
SHAWN COLE: Right.
So we're doing a financial
literacy evaluation where
we're showing financial
literacy videos to the
treatment group.
In the control group we're
bringing them in and we're
showing them films about health
or something that we
don't think will have any effect
on financial literacy,
but lots of the things
are the same.
In the medical literature they
do often double blind studies,
where you don't even know
whether you're in the
treatment group or the
control group.
So you can't get despondent for
being in the control group
because you don't know
you're there.
Sometimes these are sort of
inevitable and you can't get
around them, but you should
think about them carefully and
try to minimize the risk.
So another problem with
evaluations is sort of
behavioral responses
to evaluations.
So we assign some schools to
treatment schools and some
schools to comparison schools.
And the people in the comparison
school say, oh.
So we give textbooks to
the treatment school.
So lots of people
say, hey, this
school's got new textbooks.
I'm going to go to
this school.
And so that increases
the class size.
So the textbooks may benefit
the test score, but the
increased class size offsets
that and you find no effect of
textbooks because
the behavioral
responses undid this.
Whereas if you were to do it
throughout the country and
give every school new textbooks,
then there'd be no
transferring around because
there'd be no reason to change
schools because your school
would have free
textbooks as well.
So that's sort of another.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to go
back to your question about
how to minimize the Hawthorne
and John Henry effect.
We're doing an impact study,
impact evaluation on
microfinance product
in Mexico.
We try not to talk
about the study.
The people at the top know that
they're implementing this
study, but the participants
don't know
anything about the study.
And it's very kind of hush
hush, basically to try to
avoid changing behavior.
And obviously that's not
always possible.
But to the extent that it is,
people don't have to know that
they're part of a study.
SHAWN COLE: I'm sure everybody
here who's lived in the US has
participated in a study
sponsored by a credit card
company that does randomized
evaluations to figure out how
to get people to sign up
for their credit cards.
So they randomly send some
people 10 point font on the
outside letter, some people
12 point font
on the outside letter.
Some people 16 point font
And they keep track of who
responds and they figure out
that this is the right
font size.
And then they say, what
color should it be?
This is the right color.
What should the teaser
interest rate be?
And so lots of firms do this
without you even knowing it.
And then you won't get any John
Henry or John Hawthorne
effects because people won't
even know they're in
experiments.
Sometimes there are sort of
consent issues that you need
people's informed consent that
preclude that from happening.
There's some issues that we were
touching on before, sort
of the generalizability
of results.
So can the program be
replicated on a
large national scale?
So we're going in and giving
free soap to these villages,
but it would get expensive to
give free soap to every
village in the country.
The study sample, is
it representative?
So what's a problem you
might run into here?
AUDIENCE: If for logistical
reasons, you're only doing it
in one state in a country and
it's randomized within the
state, but then there's just
a different culture in the
state, or there's a really
strong history or traditions
in the state that then are not
generalizable up to the
country as a whole.
SHAWN COLE: A problem you often
run into is NGOs will, I
think for reasonable reasons
say, OK, let's do this study
at out best bank branch or
at our best district.
Because doing a study
is pretty hard.
You have to have treatment and
you have to have control and
keep track of who's
in which group.
And so these people have been
with us for five years and
they can do the study
really well.
And so you do the study and you
find some nice effect, but
that is the effect of putting
your best people into the
program and you only
have 20 of them.
And now when you try to scale
it up to 500 villages, you
just don't have that level of
human capital to implement the
same quality of program
elsewhere.
So sensitivity of results.
This is sort of important, but
may be second order important.
The state of the art and the
sciences, we're still looking
for things that work
and work well.
So we're not as worried about
figuring out if we give the
de-worming tablet every month
versus every three weeks,
which one is more effective.
I mean that's a useful important
question and it
probably deserves a study.
But it's hard enough to get the
big picture studies done
to then move onto the
sensitivity of the results.
That said, sometimes there are
often interesting economic
questions you have.
So you want to know whether
microfinance has an impact on
people's wealth.
But you might also care about
the interest rate.
And so for microfinance to be
sustainable, the interest rate
has to be high.
But for it to generate a lot of
income for the borrowers,
the interest rate
has to be low.
So you could try your program
at different interest rates
and see whether you find the
same effect at different
interest rates.
That would be very
interesting.
So there's often a trade-off
between internal
and external validity.
In my experience, I think it's
probably reasonable to focus
on the first pass on the
internal validity.
Because the advantage of picking
your best branch or
picking your good people to get
the study done and done
well and have a large treatment
effect is that we
were sure we know what
we're measuring.
It's often hard to measure
effects in the real world.
It's not as if the hundred
people in this room are the
first people to think
we should do
something to reduce poverty.
It's a difficult and
thorny problem.
And so if we can throw sort of
our best program and show that
our best program is effective,
then we can sort of work on
expanding and testing our
second best program.
Statistical power is often
stronger if you have a very
homogeneous sample.
So if you can randomize in a set
of twins or something like
that, you have very good
statistical power.
But twins might not be
representative of the general
population.
And then, of course, the
study location is
almost never random.
In Indonesia we did manage to do
a nationally representative
randomized evaluation of a
financial literacy program,
but that was just because the
world bank was doing a
nationally representative survey
and we persuaded them
to tack the experiment
on at the end.
But otherwise it's almost always
prohibitively expensive
to travel around to hundreds
of locations.
But at the end of the day,
you do care a lot
about external validity.
You want to know that before
you throw a lot of money at
the program, can you get
the same effect when
you scale it up?
And is this program effective
for large populations?
So in the last 5 or 10 minutes,
we'll talk a little
bit about cost effectiveness.
So you've done your program,
you've done your evaluation,
you've got the efficacy.
You know how much it costs
to deliver the program.
Now how do you decide which
program to pursue?
I guess the important thing
in this is pretty obvious.
It's just finding a metric that
you can use to compare
different programs.
So in educational programs
we often look at years of
schooling as an output.
Having an extra teacher causes
people to stay in school
longer, but extra teachers
are expensive.
You can figure out how much
it costs per child year of
schooling you create.
In health programs, they have
something called a disability
adjusted life year, which I'm
sure some of you know a lot
better than I do.
But it's basically an unimpaired
year of life with
no disability counts as one.
If your legs are immobile,
then maybe
it'd be 0.6 or something.
And it sort of gets adjusted
down to figure out which
health interventions are more
or less cost effective.
Or you could do cost
per death averted.
I think the interesting takeaway
here is that doing
these types of comparisons can
sometimes lead to pretty
surprising results.
So we know how to get people in
school by reducing the cost
of education, so the PROGRESA
program in Mexico made
conditional cash transfers
to students' parents
who attended school.
Providing free uniforms
increases attendance.
Providing school meals
We've looked at incentives
to increase learning.
But we've also looked at
the de-worming case.
If you'd said five years ago
to educational people who
specialize in education in
developing countries, what do
you think a very high impact
intervention would be?
I think very few people would
have suggested de-worming.
But if you do the math, you can
figure out that an extra
teacher will induce let's say
one year of additional
schooling, but costs
$55 per pupil.
So the cost per additional year
of schooling is here for
extra teacher.
Iron supplements here.
School meals here.
Deworming here.
So it's just tremendously cost
effective to provide this
de-worming medicine
as a means of
increasing years of education.
Much cheaper than scholarships
for girls, et cetera, or
school uniforms.
And you could do this
calculation not just for
education, you could say, there
are a lot of things that
we care about.
We care about health outcomes,
human capital investment,
externalities.
And so an interesting thing
that came out of the
de-worming study was that if you
did the old studies that
didn't take into account the
externalities and just sort of
treated some people in a school
but not other people in
a school, it didn't look like
a very good intervention.
Because the kids would keep
reinfecting each other even
though they'd just been treated,
and so it wasn't that
cost effective.
But once you did the school
level randomization and took
into account for the
externalities, then the
program turned out to look very,
very cheap as a way of
providing education.
It's also an incredibly
effective way of improving
health outcomes, de-worming.
And much more effective, for
example, than treating
schistosomiasis.
You can do even more
calculations.
You can say OK, so we know that
the deworming medicine is
going to increase years
of education by 0.2.
Well, what's 0.2 years
of education worth?
There are economists who have
done estimates of the returns
to schooling in Kenya.
They say if you get an extra
year of schooling, you're
going to get 7% more income
throughout your life.
And then so you've got
40 years of life
at 7% higher income.
You can take the present value
of that stream of additional
wage payments and you can see
that, wow, by investing only
$0.49, we're going to generate
$20 more in wages at net
present value, on average.
And so if you have a tax rate
of 10%, that's clearly a
profitable intervention
for the government if
it's patient enough.
Because it'll take in $2 in net
present value in taxes at
a cost of only $0.49
of delivering.
Of course, there may
not be any taxes on
informal labor in Kenya.
So I think this is an example we
like to cite first, because
Michael helped prepare this
particular lecture the first
time around and is fond
of that paper.
But second, I think it's a very
nice example of a program
that has a really big
macro effect.
So basically, it's been adopted
nationwide in Uganda,
and they're expanding
it a lot in Kenya.
It's been tried in India and
many other countries have
realized that this is a
tremendously effective program.
And the ability to have this
randomized evaluation, there's
very credible evidence that
said, we had these treatment
groups, these control groups.
We followed people for three
years and the reason why our
results are so different than
the other results that you
were citing as a reason not to
provide de-worming is because
of these externalities.
And we can show you why these
externalities matter.
The credibility of that study
really helped to transform
policy and literally save
thousands, tens of
thousands of lives.
Maybe more.
Other examples.
PROGRESA, which some of you
might be familiar with.
It's actually the government of
Mexico decided to integrate
a bunch of randomized
evaluations into its social
welfare programs.
That methodology and the results
of what's been shown
effective in that program have
been adopted throughout Latin
America and elsewhere.
And Ben Olken, whom you saw
earlier, did some experiments
on threat of audits in Indonesia
for corruption.
And the government of Indonesia
is increasing the
probability of audits as a way
of fighting corruption in the
nation's fourth most
populous country.
So I think the conclusion is
that these evaluations, which
take a lot of time and
take a lot of effort,
let's not kid ourselves.
If you sign up for one
of these, it's
going to be a big affair.
But it can have a tremendous
impact.
It's very important to know from
your own perspective how
effective your program
is, but you can
influence policy a lot.
So I'm just going to conclude
with two things.
One is this mention of the
additional resources, which
should be on the JPAL website.
This is a book you have
to buy for $60.
Only buy this if you're
already familiar with
econometrics.
But they're both great
treatments of the material
we've covered this week.
And I believe JPAL is in the
process of developing a
practitioner's guide as well.
This is a much more
technical guide
that's full of equations.
But hopefully, as you've seen
throughout the last week,
we've tried to explain things
in ways that are accessible
that you can explain to people
who haven't taken econometrics
and that will hopefully be
coming out pretty soon.
And so if I were just to at
least take two seconds to give
my perspective, I'm young but
I've done a few of these.
It's probably helpful when
you're doing one of these
evaluations to engage
in academics.
If you're thinking of doing
a study, you just
send an email to JPAL.
They'll send it out to their
network of 15 or 20 people and
I don't know what the
response rate is.
But I think there's a lot of
interest in doing these
experiments.
IPA is another organization
that does this.
But there's some subtle nuanced
issues that require
careful thinking through.
Or you could just call me up
and say, we're going to be
doing this study.
We're spending a lot of money
on it, can we just talk
through these issues with you?
I'd be perfectly happy
to do that.
And then, one thought.
Just a few thoughts
on keeping your
evaluation costs effective.
And maybe even think about this
when you're proposing
your program tomorrow, is that
randomizing at the individual
level where possible and
appropriate is a tremendously
useful way to keep costs down.
Because their statistical power
is so much higher, so to
detect any given effect size you
can do it with many fewer
observations.
Another way to save a lot
of money is to use
administrative data.
So if you can get people to give
you access in New York to
their checking accounts and
credit card statements, and
get those reported, at a
low cost to you, the
administrative data is often of
very high quality and can
be collected for little money.
And then the third trick is
sort of using lotteries to
ensure high compliance.
So if you sort of announce
that you've got this new
program and you let everybody
who's interested apply, and
then you sort of randomly select
60 and have 60 as a
control group, then the
compliance is going to be
pretty high in the
treatment group.
That Wald estimator, the
difference between these two
things, is going to
be pretty high.
So we're at 2:25, which at MIT
is the end of the class.
And I guess the end of the
course, at least from the
lecturing side.
So thank you very much and I
will be around here to answer
questions for the next
15 minutes if people
would like to talk.